à présent à madame Isabelle Floren pour
le groupe l'Union centriste pour 8
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues de
primabord technique la présente
proposition de loi n'en est pas moins
aussi éminemment politique je ne
reviendrai pas sur sa raison d'être
opérationnelle elle a déjà été rappelée
par l'auteur du texte mon collègue
Vincent capocanellas dont je salue
l'engagement à améliorer la mise en
œuvre d'une réforme dont l'application
se révèle complexe et qui entraîne des
conséquences pratiques importantes pour
le quotidien des Franciliens al l'heure
où dans un sondage paru le weekend
dernier il est estimé que 59 % des
Français ont le sentiment que l'action
politique n'a pas d'effets positifs sur
leur vie quotidienne je dirais que ce
texte est le bienvenu pour montrer à
cette majorité de Français qu'ils
doivent être plus attentif à notre
travail ou que nous devons peut-être
mieux communiquer sur notre travail cela
a été dit cette proposition de loi
s'impose pour mener à bien l'ouverture à
la concurrence du réseau de bus
francilien de la riratp elle s'inscrit
dans le cadre d'un processus initié il y
a 15 ans découlant de nos engagements
européens et qui nécessite aujourd'hui
une nouvelle intervention législative en
effet les circonstances ont changé
depuis l'adoption de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités du 24
décembre 2019 organisant l'ouverture à
la concurrence
elles ont changé du côté de la région
île-de-fance mobilité l'autorité
organisatrice a défin une nouvelle
architecture pour le réseau de bus la
RATP quant à elle s'est organisé pour
gagner en
compétitivité en organisant un grand
changement de son réseau de bus en avril
2019 dans ces conditions le cadre légal
du transfert des agents de la RATP aux
nouveaux opérateurs doit être amélioré
île-de- France Mobilis île-de-fance
mobilité a besoin que le calendrier de
l'ouverture à la concurrence soit
assoupli pour le dire clairement elle a
besoin de plus de temps comme l'a
remarqué Vincent capocanellas même les
salariés ont besoin que le calendrier
soit tenu pour savoir à quoi s'en tenir
le choix d'un assouplissement du
calendrier de 2 ans entre le 31 décembre
2024 et le 31 2026 est finalement comme
l'ensemble du texte un choix de
tempérance l'objectif partagé par toutes
les partie prenante et d'assurer une
transition la plus fluide possible et la
continuité du service public c'est là
que l'on envient à l'aspect politique du
Tex du texte sous un angle de dimension
sociale son objet est ni plus ni moins
que d'organiser le transfert de 19000
agents de la RATP aux n nouveaux
opérateurs de bus l'équivalent de la
population d'une ville moyenne la
présente proposition de loi est donc
avant tout une loi une proposition de
loi de protection des salariés concernés
son objet central est de leur garantir
que l'on exigera pas d'eux une mobilité
non
consentie son article 1er permet
explicitement le transfert des salariés
des centrebus avec maintien sur site ou
recours au volontariat pour changer de
site ces gens ces enjeux sont à juste
titre sensibles pour les salariés de la
RATP ils le sont aussi pour les
francilien car il s'agit pour eux de
garantir que l'ouverture à la
concurrence ne se traduise pas par une
dégradation du service tant sur les
grandes lignes que sur les navettes
locales dont la gestion a été déléguée à
la RATP je sais que de nombreuses
réflexions sont en cours sur le devenir
de ces liaisons locales notamment dans
le département des Hautes scènes lorsque
l'on sait les difficultés auxquelles la
RATP est confrontée actuellement pour
recruter des machinistes on mesure à
quel point le risque est réel il
suffirait que le transfert de ces agents
aux nouveaux opérateurs dégrade un peu
plus l'attractivité du métier pour que
cela soit catastrophique est-ce utile de
dire que sans chauffeur même avec la
meilleure volonté du monde on ne peut
pas assurer de Service Bus enfin ce
texte ne vient pas de nulle part
il est issu d'une concertation avec les
représentants des agents concernés avec
le gouvernement et avec la région bien
sûr tous ont su parvenir à un consensus
ce qui n'est pas un 20 mot quand on se
souvient à quel point le débat sur les
transfors a pu être a pu être tendu par
le passé son processus d'élaboration est
donc exemplaire de ce que nous devrions
nous efforcer de faire à chaque fois le
groupe de l'Union centriste soutiendra
la présente proposition de loi avec
d'autant plus de force qu'elle a été
enrichie par son examen en commission
sous la houlette de notre rapporteur
Franck dersin dont je salue l'excellent
travail lui qui n'a pas eu une minute
entre son arrivée au Sénat et le début
des auditions qu'il a dû mener pour
endosser ce rapport notre commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable a apporté au texte
des améliorations non négligeables
notamment la modif iation de la période
de référence pour la détermination du
nombre de salariés transférés aux
nouveaux employeurs ou l'allongement de
à 6 mois au lieu des 4 mois actuels de
la période durant laquelle les salariés
devront être informés des conditions du
transfert de leur contrat de travail ce
ne sont pas des détails ces
modifications auront une portée concrète
et pratique véritable pardelà ces
interventions ponctuelles notre
rapporteur a eu à cœur de ne pas
bouleverser l'équilibre de texte fruit
de négociation et de compromis un
équilibre savant qui concilie les
spécificités du statut des personnel de
la RATP le cadre européen et les
contraintes opérationnelles pesant sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence vous l'orez
compris mes chers collègues le groupe de
l'Union centriste votera unanimement en
faveur de ce
texte merci la